[Music]
a garrulous grandmother and a roaming
bandit face off on a dirt road a Bible
salesman lures a one-legged philosopher
into a barn a travelling handyman
teaches a deaf woman her first word on
an old plantation from her farm in rural
Georgia surrounded by a flock of pet
birds Flannery O'Connor scribbled tales
of outcasts intruders and misfits staged
in the world she knew best the American
South she published two novels but is
perhaps best known for her short stories
which explored small town life with
stinging language offbeat humor and
delightfully unsavory scenarios in her
spare time O'Connor drew cartoons and
her writing is also brimming with
caricature in her stories a mother has a
face as broad and innocent as a cabbage
a man has as much Drive as a floor mop
and one woman's body is shaped like a
funeral urn the names of her characters
are equally sly take the story the life
you save may be your own where the
one-handed drifter Tom shifflett wanders
into the lives of an old woman named
Lucy knell crater and her deaf and mute
daughter though mrs. crater is
self-assured her isolated home is
falling apart at first we may be
suspicious of shifflet's motives when he
offers to help around the house but
O'Connor soon reveals the old woman to
be just as scheming as her unexpected
guest and rattles the readers
presumptions about who has the upper
hand for O'Connor no subject was
off-limits though she was a devout
Catholic she wasn't afraid to explore
the possibility of pious thought and
unbiased behavior coexisting in the same
person in her novel the violent Barrett
away the main character grapples with
the choice to become a man of God but
also sets fires and commits murder the
book opens with the reluctant prophet in
a particularly compromising position
Francis Marion Tarr waters uncle had
been dead for only half a day when the
boy got too drunk to finish digging his
grave this leaves a passerby to drag the
body from the breakfast table where it
was still sitting and bury it with
enough dirt on top to keep the dogs from
digging it up
though her own politics are still
debated O'Connor's fiction could also be
attuned to the racism of the South in
everything that rises must converge she
depicts his son raging at his mother's
bigotry but the story reveals that he
has his own blind spots and suggests
that simply recognizing evil doesn't
exempt his character from scrutiny even
as O'Connor probes the most unsavory
aspects of humanity she leaves the door
to redemption open a crack in a good man
is hard to find
she redeems an insufferable grandmother
for forgiving a hardened criminal even
as he closes in on her family though we
might balk at the price the woman pays
for this Redemption were forced to
confront the nuance in moments we might
otherwise consider purely violent or
evil O'Connor's mastery of the grotesque
and her explorations of the insularity
and superstition of the South led her to
be classified as a Southern gothic
writer but her work pushed beyond the
purely ridiculous and frightening
characteristics associated with the
genre too revealed a variety and nuance
of human character she knew some of this
variety was uncomfortable and that her
stories could be an acquired taste but
she took pleasure in challenging her
readers O'Connor died of lupus at the
age of 39 after the disease had mostly
confined her to her farm in Georgia for
12 years during those years
she penned much of her most imaginative
work her ability to flip between
revulsion and revelation continues to
draw readers to her endlessly surprising
fictional worlds as her character Tom
shifflett notes the body is like a house
it don't go anywhere but the spirit lady
is like an automobile always on the move
looking for your next book check out our
ted-ed book rex list to get more reading
recommendations
[Music]